EUTERS TODAY OINING I WANT TO SH
ISRAEL, IS BEGINNING TADIRD SHO
HERE IN  STATES E T
OU THINK BOOSTERS COULD
LP WELL, CERTAINLY THE
RDT, A, TA AND INFORMA, WEO T N
RIOSE O DOSES
YOU GET WITH THE
ONGOING AS WE SPEAK ABOU CONTINE
LOOKING AT THEBILITY
IF AND WHEN WE SHOULD BEBOOSTIN.
SO THIIS WE
SAY, NE DON'T NEED A BOOST
RI
FOREVER.
WORK GOING ON  EXAMINE THI REA
WE MIGHBUT RIGHT NOVEN THE
THAT THE AND THEDA HAS
THEY DON'T FEEE NE TTELL PW YOU.
WONDERD AT ALL
THAT IF THE C AND FDA CHANCOMME
BOOSTERS DO BECOED IN MONTHS, T
AMERICANS WILL --
SOME DEMAGOGUES INEDIAL RTY THI
ST IN THE FDA AND
CDC.
YOU HAVVERY
METHING KEWIED
REALLY
IMPORTANT  UTHAT,
A THGUNENTS OF AVE AN GANIZACD
ATHE
PUA
MENDATION, IT HA BASED ON DAHAAC
EFORE YOU GETT DATA, THERE
WELL-MEANING PEOPLE AND WELL-MEO
EAD ANVEAT'S NOT A FORMAL
RECOMMENDATION.
I  INDIVIDUAL
PHYSI
PHYSICIANS, WE KNOW SOME
PHYSICIANS RIGSAYING,  EXTRA
STEP GO TH W
T ACTUALLY HAVE
A LOWER LEVEL  IMM
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
AT FORL RECOMMENDATIONS
ONS ALWAYS B
AND AS WE'VEAID Y TIMEJAKE, DATO
AT
EVOLVE.D I  SOMETIMES IT'S
T,HEN YOU GE
DATIONS FROM
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE CDC
THAT F VACCID  WHAT CALLED
INDUALS WHO HAVE BEECTED WITH C.
TKTHROUGH CASES THAT RESULT
INR T  PREMATURE TO
TL BREAKTHROUGHN THT
TATHOULDN'T THE CDC JU CONTINUE
RACK BTH
INFECTIO?NDING THAT,
KE ANT.
'TT IS THE IMPORTANT I
T WE HAVE OU HAVBREAKTHROUGH
THAT MIGHT ERE,
ULTIMATELY LEAD S STILL , VEH I
EFFECTIVENESS, WELL INTO THE
DO OUGH.
THE QUESTION THAT YOU'REIN
ARENE A'LL BE
SEEING M TESTING BEINGDONE.BEINH
>> THE NUMBER IN E U.S. HT DOU
FRTSO
19,000EW CASES A DROM
VARIAN
MOLF OF NEINFECTIONS.
WE KNOW  MORENOUGH VACCINES FORI
HEATES KNOW, JAKE,T'ICABLE PUSH
CE YOU TATE.YO AWHILO TON ABOUU
THAT IS NOTHE CASE A
E TRUSTEMESSAG
TE TO
UNDERSTAND ANDE WHY
FOR O
SAFETY, FOR THAT OEIR
IN GENERAL.D FOR THETY
T   VEROD POINT.
E N THE
WE S ICALLY NIL.E PLACES WOULD E
ENOUGHONS TOIV
IDLOR GO PUT ASIDE TNG.
ENCES THKIT
SOMEBODY IS FORCO
SOMETHING.
PUOFFIS,
LIKE MYSELF ANOLE ASKI TO DO SO
THAT WILL ULMA SAVYOF D THAT
SOSO, JAKE, I DON'KNOW.
I REALLY DON'T HAVEXAN WHY
THHAPPINI , IT'S IDEOLOGICALDI
EASON NOT TO.
WHY ARE WE HAVING RED STATND
PLACES IN TH
IG ONE WT ATIONS?
VACCINATIONS HAVE NOTHING TO DO
THT OW ALICAN N INDEPENDENT. I O
FOR SURETHAT.
ANT THER TDIVIDE OF
PEOPLETIO GEVACCINATED
AND NTING TO GET VACCINATE REAU.
>> C CPA GOITHIS
NT A CLIP OF
SPEAKER
GOVERNMENT WAS HOPING TH
ON INT
VACCINATED.
YOPPENING, RIGHT
RI JUST GOESON ANOT TRUEBONE.
E WAS NOT ABLEO ACHIEVA VAAL.LIH
WHAT'S Y WHEN YO
THAT?
NG.
I MEG ABOUT D
R  LIVES.MEANT UNPACK
FRIGHTENING TO SAY,  GUESS
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO D
Y  SCREAMING ANDAPON THAT.
I MEAN, AND DOT THTH WHO IS
CAN GET THAT.
WH IS THAT
>> ON THR DEECTRUME FORM
HEALTH AND HUMANS
SEBELIUS, SAID THIS E'TRATED.
SHE THINKS IT'S ME
RAPUSH
S AND SI A
MANDATE TH
SHE SAID QUOTE,
I'M O RESTRAIN MYSBUT I'VEIN
MANDATES.E'OITO
IT'S LIK OVE
THWANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE I
DET HAVE TO SO IT TRANSMITT TOG.
SEBELIUS IFRUSTRATION A LOT OFT
OFFENPEREFUSET VACCINATED.
PEOPLE WHO AREVACCINATINO WEAROS
THAT YOU HAV
THT BEENR
MAININES, BUT OU
IRATIONS>> RIGHT.LSSTO
I REMAIN OATNILOLEVEL,
JAKE, THERE
MA
THERE ALHOULD BEWE'RE TAT LIFE .
WEE LOST 600,000 A
ALREADY, AND WE.ERE HAVE BEEN DT
WORLDWIDE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WIL
HAAN
HESITANCY ATHEAL ONDE
H
OF SAFETY ISE THAN WE'VE TOFT N
EVERN WITH THECY USEAUTHORIZATIS
ARE AS GOOASAPPROV W DOTTED
Ts CROSSED
THINGS.'T CAUSE S TOCERTAIN
BUT IT'SS SO PEOPLE SHOULD R TH.
BUT THEYRE WAITING NOW UNTILT